foreign
Ty kicks us off this hour in Chicago
Courtney welcome to the Ramsey show how
can we help
thank you so much for taking my call I
really appreciate your guys's time
absolutely um yeah thanks okay so I have
been divorced for about six years I'm 39
almost 40. and my boyfriend and I have
been talking about getting married
um what makes me nervous is I'm in a
much better situation financially than
he is and I have a lot of questions on
prenups I have two kids I own a business
I have a lot of assets and everything I
just I'm really just like confused about
what's the right thing to do and still
protecting me and my kids but you know
all that all that jazz understandable so
tell us about your financial situation
what are your assets your net worth and
your income
sure um okay
yeah so I I say take home about 150 000
a year I have no debt
um I have two vehicles that I own
um I have about a hundred thousand
dollars in my savings account about four
hundred thousand in various retirement
accounts
um I have two kids and then my boyfriend
is also debt free except for his
mortgage which only has about a hundred
thousand left on it he makes about 60
000 a year as a restaurant manager
general manager the only thing is he has
zero retirement and he also has he
doesn't have any children so retirement
is really like my biggest like hang up I
would say
um so I don't really know how to
navigate that
can I ask you a question
um if let's let's pretend that things go
well in the more in the marriage as we
expect that they would
and you have you know this retirement
Nest Egg set aside do you view that as
something that you guys share together
or do you view that as this is my
retirement and he has his retirement
that's that's what I'm like really
wrestling because in the perfect world I
would see it as something shared but I
just know how how really hard I've like
worked for it and like all the
sacrifices that I've made as like a
single mom and
um just like really like smart choices
that I've had to make to do it it does
it makes me really nervous
okay I could see how that would make you
nervous but I do think that there's
um it's unfair I think to go into it to
a marriage where you're saying I do
we're gonna be one but I worked really
hard for what I have and so I think that
I should be able to have that over here
I think if the tables were turned that
might be a little bit off-putting for
you I I yeah I totally understand that I
think what makes me nervous is he has
something he has zero retirement he's
only he kind of I mean being in the
restaurant industry he's never been at a
place where they offer any kind of like
investment like 401k or anything and
he's he's 40 years old too so is he
against contributing to a Roth IRA on
his own when he he I keep I keep
suggesting that and encouraging that but
he just never seems to get there if that
makes any sense
um I even gave him my like financial
planner's information and it just he I
don't know he always says I played phone
tag I'm not sure but he says he is
so there's some things you guys agree on
about money like you both agree dead is
bad because neither of you have debt
but yeah we just owned two cars straight
out he is very he's very frugal with his
money he's not like an overspender he
you know that I do admire and that's
great it's the it's really the
retirement thing that's really like a
hang up for me what would be the
long-term plan let's say you guys get
married 22 years from now you guys
decide to retire what happens then
that's what I keep asking and he just I
feel like his parents never taught him
like anything with that even though
they're retired and his dad had worked
for a union so that's how he you know
that was his retirement thing but they
never really pushed him to like think
about that or to be in a career that you
know he never had any skin in the game
for like his college they paid for all
of his college which he has nothing to
do with the major but he's in so I feel
like he he doesn't like think about that
so My worry is less about this prenup
and it's more that you guys aren't on
the same page financially the prenup is
just kind of a formality after we have
the discussion and go hey there's all
this wealth over here this is not a
trust issue between the people it's we
don't want to invite crazy into our life
it's more about the people in your
circles than it is about you two yeah
and this sounds like I don't want him
mooching off of what I worked hard for
later on if it doesn't work yeah that's
the spirit of it you set some things off
to the side that were kind of I dare I
say pass lots of aggressive you're like
he's not even in his degree field so I
you have I'm just gonna say you've got a
little beef here that you need to cook
it up you all need to cook it up
together and eat it because if you get
married without doing that it doesn't
matter if you have a prenup it's always
going to bother you that there's these
checklists in your brain that he's not
checking the box now I do wonder if we
were to give you Financial Peace
University would he go through that with
you or would he say no I don't need that
um no I think he would yeah no I think
he's he's open I think I think more or
less he's just clueless so he just it's
just a lack of Education
yeah yeah okay well here's the thing if
he's if it's a lack of education but
he's open to learning it and doing the
things and he's like hey there's a class
yes I will go to the class with you
Courtney
um I think that's that's a green flag
but if the if the answer is no I don't
need that you know I never grew up and
he's closed off to it that's a giant red
flag and that's something that you need
to consider and a prenup in my mind is
not the answer it's digging deeper and
asking more questions to find out if
there's more red flags than if there's
more red flags then you can kick him to
the curb but
um do you have a paid for house Courtney
do you have a paid for a house
I actually rent oh okay okay so he's
coming to table with uh with home
ownership
the spices things up it does that's
that's a green flag so here's my thing
important if you do I don't think this
is necessary in this scenario you it's
not like you're coming to the table with
four million dollars and he's broke
right no he's doing fine he's doing
great but we need to get him on the
investing side and he doesn't have that
financial literacy background that you
do you've done so so well and I'm really
proud of you so if you do go forward
with this prenup you both talk about it
you say hey this is to protect the
relationship this is not a trust issue
this is to protect us from crazy down
the line but be open to revisions maybe
make it protective at first but five
years down the line say we're gonna
revise this and it's going to be all
ours now
so it's not one thing set in stone
forever and again come to the
conversation without it being uh I don't
trust you you're broke and if we're
going to go through with this thing uh
it's gonna be my money but that is what
it is though unless that is the spirit
of it right now yeah and so that's what
worries me I think we got to do some
soul searching before we move forward
with this relationship or with the
prenup
okay thank you so much I appreciate it
you got it Courtney wishing you the best
congrats on all the success